are you guys what is where you from I'm
from Toronto Canada it's a Christmas
movie you love Christmas guys have any
amazing holiday traditions speaking of
cool wine or what kind of alcohol
whatever gets the job done no I'm
kidding
what was the question tradition family
might honest tradition is family but my
parents have always been so great about
instilling family time during any
holiday
we're non-secular household we celebrate
any holiday in every holiday so long as
there's an excuse to get the family
together mmm and it's one of those
things that I hope to pass on to my
family you're a mom mom stone and joy
they give joy she's gonna keep treating
you like this until you fight her
physically I don't want you to meet my
mom how much fun do you guys have making
us just awful time I really just like
how'd you get through it how many drinks
when you have the kids around are you
loud yeah if you can handle an emergency
it's okay
look bad moms are not irresponsible
mom's bad ones are bad moms because they
take time for self-care so they don't
implode if you can still handle a broken
arm yeah you're fine then you're okay
just be able to always be able to drive
is my theory like just drink enough for
your teeter-tottering that like oh I'm
tipsy staying that happy tips ease up
every time I think I'm the weird one in
this group you open your mouth we went
to prom together
oh boy and then I'm like I'm doing great
well you guys apprehends us too
sometimes when you do an amazing time we
didn't have any time to be apprehensive
you don't understand we're working one
to two yeah there was like and take a
deep breath pop out a baby moving oh
that was literally I got pregnant today
we wrapped and I was on set with a
three-month-old just grabbed mom's baby
yeah
did they time it around your pregnancy
yeah it sounds like I was perfect yes
and no I mean I wanted to work a little
bit earlier than I anticipated
but it was a great movie and it needed
to be told in the story was
awesome and I wanted to hit these girls
so my kid got schlepped with me and they
had to suffer through a lot of pumping
as parents you know you post something
that's you know on Instagram it has
nothing to do with this story that's
actually taken by the media are you
aware that and what your thoughts on how
it's kind of it's taking over I feel
like I understand that it's sort of for
me a little bit more of a business like
I'm choosing what I'm posting not
because I'm like desperate to be looked
at I'm choosing because I'm thinking
like what would fans want to see what's
like appropriate what's what do I think
would make what's relevant what do I
think we would make me laugh you know
like because that's the truth like I
want people to smile when they're on
social media like you create this is an
honest question do you curate a story
like it do you feel like you have see
curating like a story or like your
narrative yeah is that sometimes yeah
like I say is this it is this Who I am I
feel something in 10 years we're gonna
have a lot more to worry about
I gotta tell you I don't know cuz I'm
more like oh I don't wanna do with my
kid on Instagram when she wants to get
in Facebook I feel weird that that is
airing up with that as a definition of
front of this so yeah yeah it's all
gonna be messed up